how are you doing today
i'm good how are you doing steven good
to see you nice to see you
uh i think i'm going to start with the
most important question first
which is um do you remember the lyrics
to either song from streets of fire
[Laughter]
oh i remember uh i remember a lot about
it i remember one of them got
got onto the charts that year it was the
80s
yeah sure walter hill 84.
84. graduated high school in that movie
well
there we go um uh jumping into why i get
to talk to you
uh for this film um i think that
i'm very curious and this is important
to me is this taking place
in an alt universe where a baby didn't
come down from the sky
and land in your you know area with
kevin costner
well it's nice to i mean i'm still the
earth mother
in this case um you know so i do have
that in common
with both characters uh
this this one's a lot sadder for me i
mean for
for the audience too in terms of the
we're dealing with a lot of human grief
here um you know we we lose a child
which there's nothing harder but
the thought of also losing our
grandchild is unacceptable
and it sets her on her journey and you
know
kevin costner's a saint uh
both as a you know artist and also
in this character uh in terms of the
patience that he has for his wife
and how she's processing the grief no
completely um being uh i thought
your work with kevin in man of steel and
your work in this
uh it's both both filmed you guys are
fantastic together
so i guess what i want to ask is what do
we need to do to get you guys to make
more movies together
oh not much uh great screenplay helps
i mean it really did fall off hill with
this screenplay i i think
i mean if it's on the page it has a hope
of getting to the stage
um you know and kevin knows a good
screenplay when he when he finds one um
so yeah i i i would
i would be thrilled to work with him
again because i think that
we're we're actually pretty versatile
and uh
you know we don't have to be long
married couple again
we could try something different but uh
i would work with him again in a
heartbeat and he's such a
kind uh kind leader
you guys you guys really are fantastic
together and fantastic in this
um i've been asking this question of a
lot of the actors i've been talking to
recently which is um
do you remember the last time that you
were really nervous to film
something on a set and why
well it all depends i mean
possibly riding a horse in this film
i was pretty nervous about that uh you
know we were
we were pretty close to the cliff there
and i don't know how much a horse weighs
but
it it you know whatever it wants to do
will be
the deciding factor of what happens
so you want to you want to make sure
your horse likes you
uh or at least respects you um and
sometimes those
those aren't the same thing so i guess
it's more important to have respect
although
i don't know being liked is is equally
important
uh completely on that note i'm already
out of time i'm just gonna say and i
mean it congrats
uh uh i hope it's a huge hit thank you
you're very dear stay safe good to see
you